[Music]
today i'm very excited actually to
cancel a woman by the name of lindsay go
this i believe is one of the most highly
deserved cancellations we've done in
several weeks so of course they're all
highly deserved our friend lindsey is a
sports reporter and also the sports
director over at wtoc in georgia now to
be a sports reporter in georgia
you have to know and love college
football because your audience knows and
loves college football and part of
loving college football is loving the
atmosphere the experience
now it's not for everybody certainly the
game of football is fast and violent and
intense and
sometimes brutal
the experience of watching the game live
in the stadium especially a college
stadium is loud and rowdy and soaked in
beer with people screaming out of anger
and out of joy often switching between
the two from second to second
as a football fan myself this all sounds
like a tremendous amount of fun to me
but as i said it's not for everybody
and i'm afraid it's not for lindsay so
on saturday night um georgia defeated
clemson at home in a hard-fought 10-3
victory
lindsay was reporting at the stadium
and decided to set up for a live shot
right at the exits as 90 000 drunk and
deliriously excited football fans were
filing out she chose to set up her
cameras
in the midst of this swarm
and then was less than pleased with the
results later that night she tweeted
got all kinds of violated during my
first live hit by fans
she also claimed that she'd been groped
quote unquote
and she said after that
the experience was uh that she was
stressed by the experience and startled
and quote frazzled
but courageously she assured the public
that she was okay
then the next day as the nation waited
with baited breath for an update from
lindsay who was stressed and frazzled at
the football game
she finally released the footage
now it's up to the eye of the beholder
or the beer holder as the case may be to
decide
whether lindsay was in fact groped and
violated or whether she was simply
greeted with the kind of boozy
enthusiasm that literally anyone
standing in front of a camera in that
situation would have experienced and
that's up to you to decide
but uh let's watch the footage here here
it is
hello
we're hitting defensive slugfest and the
dogs ran away with it a
how long do i
okay my only problem watching that is
all the people who
uh you know they got their time in the
sun they got their time on camera and
then they kind of froze and they had
nothing to say i mean if you're gonna if
you're gonna intrude into the shot
i respect it because again we're out of
you're at a football game that's what
you do but you should have something to
say a couple people they kind of stuck
their head into the shot and like didn't
they couldn't think of anything to say
so they just walked away
um now as far as i can tell only one
person made physical contact with her by
touching her on the shoulder
and as i always tell i tell my kids all
the time you got to keep your hands to
yourself it is impolite to touch
somebody on the shoulder like that when
they don't want to be touched
but um does that qualify as groping now
has a person been violated because
another person made non-consensual
contact with their shoulder for 10
seconds or two seconds really
if so then we have all been groped
we have all been groped and violated
thousands of times in our lives
and meanwhile the the stories of women
who have actually been groped and
violated are buried somewhere under this
avalanche of brief benign non-sexual
incidental physical contact between
human beings
as for the rest of it lindsay was
encountering what again anybody
who has set up any kind of camera
outside of any college or professional
sporting event has encountered
the crazy thing is you can see in her
face
from the beginning
that she has no patience for any noise
at all
she doesn't appear to want to be there
to begin with
and as soon as people start walking past
she's fuming mad
but but she's the one who set up the
camera exactly where thousands of people
will be walking this is like a guy from
the weather channel reporting live from
the beach during a hurricane and whining
the whole time because his hair is
getting wet
it's like if i tried to make a phone
call while sitting in the stands at a
nascar race like hang on a second hey
fellas can you pop the brakes for a
minute and i'm trying to have a
conversation here
of course that's that's not to say that
reporters can't or shouldn't report live
from stadiums it's just to say that they
should be ready to match the volume
intensity and exuberance of the crowd in
the background
and i certainly don't want to claim
that this is one of the reasons why men
make better sports reporters
i don't want to claim that
so i'm not going to claim that
instead instead i'll just show you an
example of how it's supposed to be done
watch this
oh it's been 644 days the last time
williams price did not have restrictions
as to how many fans could be in their
stadium but that ends tonight and while
that ends a new chapter begins as shane
beamer begins his new era as the head
football coach at the university of
south carolina hello everyone and
welcome to
the front lots here at the university of
south carolina i'm mike cuba and it is
game day something gamecock fans have
been waiting for for quite some time and
look there's a lot of story lines we
could talk about we could talk about
we can talk about how eric kimbry the
former gamecock quarterback who coached
at him
these last couple of years is making his
debut as an assistant coach but perhaps
perhaps the biggest storyline
is the fact that you have a former grad
assistant coach seth norman playing
under center tonight as the starting
quarterback early in the week we had a
chance to be able to catch up with both
sev and coach beaver
wow now that was fox reporter mike uva
who in fairness to lindsay mike is
putting on an absolute clinic in that
broadcast that few sports reporters
could fully match
uh and before you say that this was this
this was different because nobody
physically touched him here he is
broadcasting from a bar during march
madness a few years ago here's a better
example watch this
is running to the sweep 16.
wow
it
[Music]
is absolutely
[Music]
people are a little bit excited you know
they're they're a little excited covered
in beer people grabbing onto his back
and his shoulders lindsey would be in
counseling for a year after that
experience that's what i i want to see
lindsay in that environment she would be
she would break down in tears
she'd be telling stories about the
trauma to her grandchildren 40 years
from now and who knows how the story
would evolve by then
now i was trying to do a live shot from
the bar and all these basketball fans
with machetes and chainsaws started
hacking me to pieces
maybe not literally but metaphorically
they were metaphorical chainsaws
now
it wouldn't be fair to say that all
female sports reporters are like lindsay
but even so
i must
say this situation only demonstrates why
i personally prefer for sports
broadcasts especially football
broadcasts to be handled mostly by men
lindsay though worse than the average
even as far as female sports reporters
go
is definitely not the only female to
enter into this mostly male space and
seek to feminize it she wants the
football stadium to be quiet and gentle
considerate respectful of personal space
she wants it to be a more feminine
environment
she's not trying to assimilate herself
into the culture of football fans she is
rather hoping that they assimilate
themselves to her
this is a problem across our culture
sports just happen to be an area where
the problem is especially pronounced and
obvious females enter into areas that
have typically catered and mostly belong
to men
and and then
often quite successfully they try to to
change them to emasculate them and
thereby destroy the primary reason for
their existence in the first place
this phenomenon is so far-reaching in
football especially that they're even
changing the rules now to make the game
itself more gentle and feminine football
is you know still violent
but it's less violent than it used to be
this year they're even focusing on
penalizing players who say mean or rude
things to each other on the football
field they've been doing this during the
preseason in the nfl
all of this
along with the token female sideline
reporters and the female analysts at
halftime it's an effort to make the game
less appealing to the people the game
was invented for to begin with
now meanwhile it should be acknowledged
women are experiencing the same problem
in the reverse female spaces are being
invaded by men often the most private
spaces like locker rooms for example but
but it's a different kind of invasion
not better it's actually worse but it's
different
because
the men invading female spaces
do try to assimilate themselves but they
assimilate themselves too much
they assimilate themselves to the point
of pretending to actually be women and
the effect ultimately is that women
don't just lose their spaces
as men have lost ours they also lose
their identity in the process
so it's a big confused mess all in all
and it all starts from the incorrect
assumption that there is something wrong
with men and women having their own
spaces their own interests their own
identities
sports reporter lindsay didn't create
this problem
but she is just one more example of it
and for that reason she is today i must
say
cancelled back to school season is upon
us and while many american kids are
excited to get back into the classroom
many others are not because these
children don't know where their meals
will be coming from this semester that's
why good ranchers has made it their
mission to donate a hundred thousand
high quality meals to kids facing food
insecurity and malnourishment this fall
semester for every box ordered through
the month of august good ranchers will
donate a nutritious meal to a child in
need help them reach their goal of 100
000 donated meals by ordering your box
today at goodranchers.com
good ranchers is an award-winning food
delivery service that ships 100 american
meat and seafood right to your door
named the best food subscription service
earlier this year good ranchers is the
fastest growing meat company in america
they source only the best american farms
so that you can trust that you're
feeding your family with the highest
possible quality meat and meals every
day plus right now you can use my code
matt to get 30 off your order plus free
shipping your purchase further is their
mission to donate 100 000 high quality
meals to children in need this is a
great cause that we should all rally
behind go to goodranchers.com matt today
use my code matt when you place your
order and let's help these guys hit
their goal
today we have the exciting opportunity
to cancel a pet food company the better
choice company makes super premium
natural pet food for millennial and gen
z pet parents
now we've already have enough fodder
here just in the opening sentence to
cancel everybody in sight but it gets
better as yahoo finance reports the very
unaptly named better choice company has
launched a new ad campaign for its halo
dog food brand and here's the marketing
pitch according to yahoo it says quote
let's face it pets are the world's best
kids that's why better choice company a
pet health and wellness company unveils
its new marketing campaign to celebrate
pet parenthood
the new halo pet campaign sets out to
validate and empower the new generation
of pet moms the campaign launches in
support of the company's new brand halo
elevate a super premium natural pet food
backed by science millennials are
delaying having children they are
however enthusiastically embracing pet
parenthood with 76 of millennials owning
a pet the new campaign from halo is
speaking to these pet moms and saying
we see you we get you we are you
now if i was a narcissist
i might think this ad campaign was made
specifically to annoy me personally
because it's got all of the elements
there
and those suspicions are not much
allayed by the actual ad itself which we
will watch now
halo makes the world's best food for the
world's best kids no not that kid this
kid you can leave this kid alone for 10
minutes and they won't destroy your
house yeah with these kids you can
actually sleep in
and shopping never ends in tears
maybe being a human parent is overrated
so if you're gonna have a kid make it a
furry one and feed them halo elevate
natural science-based nutrition for
their optimal health halo the world's
best food for the world's best kids
okay
where to begin i i don't deny that
having kids is actually more difficult
than having a dog and we'll get to that
in a moment but first of all
dogs don't destroy your house or wake
you up
what
i find it a bit concerning that nobody
this dog food company has ever actually
met a dog apparently in fact dogs tend
to be way more destructive than children
they also can significantly be
significantly noisier and more annoying
my kids have never eaten my boots or nod
on the legs of my couch or chewed on the
carpet my kids don't eat out of the
trash
my kids don't poop on the floor usually
my kids don't wake me up in the middle
of the night barking
i don't have to take my kids outside of
the dead of winter and stand there
waiting for them to take a dump in the
grass
none of my kids have ever vomited on the
kitchen tile and then tried to eat it
dog has done that though multiple times
i came home a few days ago and someone
in the house had torn into my bookshelf
and eaten two of my favorite books
guess who did that wasn't my kids i can
tell you
now i'm starting to wonder actually what
kind of kids these people have
encountered
you know what my kids can do they can
clean up after themselves okay sure it
does take a lot of coaching and often i
have to
you know deploy various methods of
encouragement shall we say to get them
to clean up but um you can actually
raise your kids to clean up after
themselves a dog will never do that if a
dog like picks up a shoe in his mouth
and walks it over to the other side of
the room right and drops it there
everybody will applaud oh look at the
dog he's so great it would take the dog
about 19 hours to clean a whole room at
that pace
my kids can do it in at least 18 hours
my kids can do other things too like
they can pour their own bowls of cereal
in the morning they can bathe themselves
um in fact
they can do literally thousands of
things that the dog cannot do and will
never be able to do and as my kids get
older they'll become even more
self-sufficient while my dog will still
be barking at leaves and crapping all
over the place
but here's the main difference between
my children and the dog
um they are my children
the dog is not my child he's a dog
i'm not the parent of my dog and you are
not the parent of your dog
so stop saying that you are
you are not a dog mommy do you know who
your dog's mommy is another dog
there's a dog that mated with another
dog and had a dog and that dog gave
birth to your dog
and that dog is your dog's mommy
you didn't mate with a dog and have a
dog i sure hope you didn't
okay not only are you not your pet's
parent but in fact your relationship
with
with and to your pet bears no
resemblance at all to the relationship a
parent has with into their actual human
child
aside from all the many functional
differences between dogs and kids the
other major difference is that within a
human nuclear family
there's an opportunity for a loving bond
which far surpasses anything you will
ever experience with any other human
much less a mangy four-legged beast i
love my kids in a way that i could never
love an animal
i know them in a way that i could never
know an animal i was there with them
when they were born i've i've cared for
them every moment of their lives i've
gotten to know them more deeply as time
has gone on we can talk and have
conversations we can share experiences
on a much deeper and more meaningful
level then you can share any experience
with a dog
my children have brought me great joy
they they uh more joy than any animal
can bring they also can make me much
angrier and more frustrated than any
animal can make me but that's only
because
they are human beings they are complex
they can be
rebellious and strong-willed they're
self-aware they have their own ideas
about the world
my dog has no ideas about anything
he's an idiot and always will be
it is much more complicated to
discipline a child right
and there's more at stake
so if you fail as a parent your child
might become a monster who inflicts
unimaginable suffering on himself and
the world if you fail as a dog owner
your dog might bite the mailman or
whatever
does this mean that it's it's better to
own dogs because it's easier no
it means that owning dogs is simpler and
easier in some respects but also much
less important
there's much less potential for
greatness and for love in its fullest
and deepest form just as you you know
you could you could climb a mountain
or you could sit on your butt and watch
tv a lot less can go wrong watching tv
it's easier and takes less effort does
that mean it's better to watch tv does
that mean that you should never climb
any mountains whether literally or
metaphorically
sure if you want to live a shallow and
meaningless life
but here's the thing if you avoid the
difficult things in life
you also are avoiding the greatest joys
and most fulfilling and most meaningful
experiences that life has to offer
this is the bargain you make when you
elect to be a dog parent quote unquote
instead of a real parent
and if your goal is just to be
comfortable and live with ease then why
not get an ant farm instead of a dog why
not stick with a goldfish or a pet rock
because the further you go down the
intelligence and self-awareness ladder
the easier it is to be a parent quote
unquote of those kinds of creatures
there's also far less potential again
for love for joy for purpose for meaning
and lord willing my kids will grow older
and long after my dog dies my kids will
start having kids of their own and their
kids will have kids and eventually i
will die and as i'm laying on my death
bed i will know and take comfort in the
fact that my children are alive they'll
be there for me in my final days just as
i was there in their
first days
i'm not going to be thinking about my
dead dog in those moments this dog i
have now will have been replaced five or
six times over by then but my legacy
will live on in my children and in
theirs
my blood will run through their veins
we'll be connected forever in this life
and the next that's parenthood
not pet ownership
now this perhaps has gotten a little too
serious for a conversation that began
with a dog food commercial but as you
may have noticed there are a few things
i hate more than when people act as
though pets are equivalent to children
they are not
and that is why the better choice dog
food company
is today canceled
[Music]
we've talked a little bit about the
unintended consequences the trade-offs
you know when it comes to efforts by the
climate alarmists and the
environmentalists
to supposedly save the planet here's
another one this is from the daily wires
says a law to conserve a species of fish
may have inadvertently led to a recent
uptick in shark attacks in the state of
new york experts interviewed by the new
york post said that sharks are returning
to the waters off long island sound
because of a boom in the population of
uh atlantic menhaden i think that's how
you pronounce
the species of fish which is a species
of fish native to the area that means
sharks have been approaching long island
beaches and the process have been coming
dangerously close to in some cases
biting beachgoers
and there have been
according to the executive director of
the south fork natural history museum
shark research and education program the
reason why people are interacting with
sharks more often this year and more
than last year is because of the
conservation efforts um
and i think it said there have been
i say there have been six beachgoers who
have been victim to shark attacks
already so far this summer in new york
by the way i love that euphemism
for
and i like that there are people out
there doing some pr cover
for sharks by saying it's an interaction
i very well i had an interest i had an
interesting interaction with a shark
today
then you show your bloody stump of a leg
now you might expect that my take here
will be that the fish conservation was a
bad idea
because now humans are suffering from
shark attacks because of it
but
i'm going to surprise you and say no
that's actually not my opinion
that's not my take because if the reason
is that it's hard for me to sympathize
with shark attack victims at all
because
the act of getting into the ocean
is such a strange thing to me
it's it's one of the strangest behaviors
that humans engage in
is to get into the ocean
you've got this massive
vat of water
hundreds of feet deep
pummeling the shore violently with with
waves
this deep dark salty pool of death
filled with man-eating monsters and
other other beasts unknown to us
we don't even know everything that's
down there
we just know that it's hideous and
monstrous looking
and you're floating around you have all
of that
death underneath you
it's impossible to know exactly what's
lurking under the surface
and our response is to get into it
and then the worst are people that like
if you're if you're if you surf or
something then i can
it's not my thing but okay that's a
recreational activity i can sort of
understand it does look sort of fun to
do but most people who get into the
ocean they don't even do anything they
just kind of like
stand there and let the salty water
pummel them in the face for 45 minutes
and then they get out
it's a very odd behavior so you are look
when you get into the ocean you are you
are getting in this is where the sharks
live this is their home they can't live
anywhere else in fairness to them
so uh you are entering into the home you
are knocking on the door of mr shark and
saying may i come in and that's
when you look at it like that it just
doesn't make a lot of sense
[Music]